bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans le 7-8
sport numéro 33 c'est parti pour un
nouveau tour de l'actu pop du
département en 26 minutes ils sont
passés à deux points d'un titre de
champion de france les juniors des
cougars de montigny se sont inclinés en
finale ce week-end face au paris
université club film de ce match à
suivre les féminines de l'aes montini
elles ont enfin débloqué le compteur
victoire après cinq défaites en autant
de journées lésigny monteyne ont donné
un peu de répit à leur entraîneur
jordanie grossesse et enfin notre
portrait de la semaine il s'appelle
xavier bnr il a 31 ans et partage sa vie
entre les terrains de volleyball et le
technocentre de guyancourt il est en
effet le capitaine de l'équipe de france
de volley ball mais des sourds et en fin
d'émission évidemment comme d'habitude
tous les résultats du week-end mais
place tout d'abord à notre page spéciale
baseball après la phase finale des
juniors ce week end
je le disais dans le sommaire de cette
émission les juniors des cougars de
montigny sont passés à deux petits
points du titre de champion de france ce
week-end lors des phases finales et pour
débriefer ce week-end à mi-court ton la
présidente du club accompagné de
jean-françois duchaussoy sont venus
passer en tout cas un petit moment sur
le cfid sport bonsoir à tous les sens
avant des versions débrief y ait un
petit peu plus longuement ce match et
cette phase finale je vous propose de
regarder le récit de ce week-end j'étais
présent au stade jean maréchal les
juniors débuté par une demi-finale face
aux squales de vauréal samedi matin
dans cette demi finale face à vauréal
désigné mon teint sont mis sur orbite
par le lanceur frédéric walther réussi
l'exploit de réaliser dire retrait en
l'espace de quatre manches avec en prime
un auditeur sur sa prestation
de quoi ouvrir le boulevard pour les
frappeurs et notamment you qui dès son
premier passage à la batte le jeune
cougars en flammes jean maréchal
derrière lui les inimités enchaîne les
points pour mener après quatre manches
13 0 au bout de cinq manches la messe
est dite ou 21,6 les cougars s'envole
vers la finale c'est impressionnant mais
c'était pas gagné parce que portent les
luminaires cette équipe même équipe vous
avez mis 14 ans quand même on l'avait je
pense que c'est le pôle match du tour
préliminaire on n'avait pas pris au
sérieux enfin en tout cas pas assez au
sérieux et c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui
on a on a fait le nécessaire pour que on
est arrivé on voulait on voulait on
avait un petit esprit de revanche et il
fallait le remettre un gros score parce
que voilà on voulait la finale et en
plus ce qu'on avait ce petit esprit on
avait pris une fessée on voulait pas à
oreille pour prendre une deuxième le
dimanche les joueurs de rodolphe le meur
sont opposés aux vice-champions de
france 2012 le paris université club
après les deux premières manches montini
ne mène que d'un petit point grâce à la
pépite yuki ensuite les lanceurs
neutralise les frappeurs jusqu'à la
sixième manche le puc inscrits alors les
cinq points du titre dans les deux
dernières rotations le rêve et nîmes ont
un passé cela fait six ans que cela dure
mais l'avenir est prometteur et les
saint quentinois pourront tout de même
se consoler avec yuki & fred walter
l'ue respectivement meilleur frappeur et
meilleur joueur des finales
ah non c'est pas trop dur de revoir ces
images après la après la défaite d'hier
pas du tout puisque hier c'était un
match vraiment magnifique ils nous ont
fait plaisir ils n'ont rien lâché se
sont battus non nous avons vu un beau
match baseball donc non c'est pas trop
dur nous avons pris beaucoup de plaisir
et ça fait encore plaisir de revoir ces
images jean maréchal était plein pendant
tout le week-end s'est passé tout près
un jean-françois en finale oh oui moi
qui commentait le match entre autres
j'ai bien j'ai dû bien suivre le match
et bien pouvoir le commenter sur tout et
franchement ils sont passés à quelque
chose à côté de quelque chose de très
gros et je pense que il y aurait pu y
avoir une manche supplémentaire monty
n'y aurait pu repasser devant signalent
les équipes faisaient que se passer
l'une devant l'autre et tout est en fin
de compte ce sont les frappes de
l'équipe adverse qui ont fait la
différence oui le puck fait la
différence dans les deux dernières
manches dernier elle a vraiment ya eu un
déclic de leur côté à je pense oui puis
bon on vous faut dire aussi il ya eu
quelques erreurs défensives peut-être
due par le par le stress de l'événement
quoi tout ça puis vraiment les tribunes
pleines avec la pression qu'il y avait
je peux comprendre que ça pouvait que ça
pouvait un petit peu année du stress ou
joueurs mais franchement franchement
j'étais très fier de ces deux de cette
équipe est vraiment vraiment moi j'ai
cru jusqu'au bout quoi j'ai même mais
même qu'ils aient perdu je suis pas déçu
parce qu'ils ont été ils ont montré un
match digne d'une d1 ou d'une des deux
quoi mon club vraiment fabuleux quoi oui
c'est ce que me disait rodolphe le meur
et l'entraîneur des juniors mission
accomplie puisque c'était l'objectif les
phases finales on reste fier et puis on
oublie un petit peu la déception du
titre passé tout à fait oui ils ont fait
une excellente saison ils sont quand
même champion d'île de france ils ont
gagné le tournoi de la guerche il arrive
vice-champion de france pour une équipe
pour certains joueurs qui ont commencé
le baseball il ya trois quatre ans donc
non vraiment ils ont atteint leur
objectif
il ya on ne peut que les féliciter et
toute façon le ce qu'ils ont dit on
après la défaite ça a été de toute façon
lors à l'année prochaine donc on compte
sur elle à des prochaines esprit de
profiteurs et de revanche des canadiens
il ya une marge de progression
importante sur ce groupe à jean-françois
où ça peut peut-être encore stagner non
moi je moi je pense qu'en plus bon là il
y avait là l'équipe était vraiment au
complet parce qu'ils ont profité aussi
de de quatre joueurs qui venaient de la
15e championne de france la semaine
d'avant entre haute et ça le rapport se
la ramener beaucoup de bien parce que
c'était des joueurs qui sont en équipe
de france cadets qui ont un bon
potentiel de lancer donc ça fait du bien
à l'équipe à l'équipe 18 tu mets des
joueurs avaient été méritants dans cette
équipe 18 u donc je pense que comme
disait annie l'année prochaine le titre
un an mais même si bien sûr il n'y a pas
photo je veux pas dire assez va cesser
c'est jean-françois montigny qui veut
que les non non moi je le sais avec le
potentiel puisque j'ai eu ces joueurs
l'année d'avant dieu pour le je vous le
rappelle françois vous êtes l'entraîneur
des quinze bus et oui voilà voilà vous
les voyez un petit peu grandir à limoges
pour les paris pour l'année prochaine du
coup à nous le ferons tout de suite moi
j'ai livré deux champions de france
allaient prochaine cc enregistré 6 pour
montrer la séquence dans un an alors un
nos produits et il ya deux joueurs sur
lesquels je voudrais revenir pendant
cette finale c'est fred walter et yuki
j'en parlais dans le sujet dans le récit
de ce match ils ont été exceptionnels
tout le week-end à 10h ils ont été
merveilleux yuki est un joueur fabuleux
c'est un japonais dedans pour lui ne
lâchera jamais rien il a toujours le
sourire il entraîne l'équipe et puis
fred fred aussi c'est un joueur
magnifique à elle fait du baseball
depuis qu'il a 4 ans à montigny et il a
lancé un rappel si les lanceurs oui mais
voilà commencé tout petit il a toujours
bien progresser maintenant il est au
pôle de toulouse il est en équipe de
france c'est vraiment un espoir très
très fort pour le baseball français yuki
un rôle particulier aussi j'en conçois
classe qui les catcheurs quoi ils sont
un peu tout en fait en dix ans c'est lui
qui dirige la tâche qui dirige la
défense la défense puisque c'est lui qui
voit un peu s'il peut y avoir un joueur
qui va voler une base un joueur adverse
entre autres c'est lui qui dirige tout
cas défense et qui peut demander à la
défense de se rapprocher un peu tout ça
mais c'est vraiment c'est vraiment un
joueur exceptionnel en plus ça au bâton
il est magnifique et puis il ya de
frédéric walther que je pense ou robin
qui se reconnaîtra qui peut courir aussi
vite que lui parce que quand il est sur
bazas et un feu follet quoi faut c'est
vraiment un joueur extraordinaire et
nous l'a prouvé en little league oui où
il a fait des jeux extraordinaires même
des autres équipes encourage l ue qui
dans les tribunes italienne entendait
encourager ou qui donc ça prouve qu'il a
il a montré quelque chose et frédéric
walther bon bah c'est un joueur hors du
commun en du commun pour revenir sur
l'ensemble des jeunes un vous le disiez
jean-françois les 15 du champion de
france cette année et ce vis de ce titre
de vice champion de france chez les
juniors l'avenir est prometteur du côté
des gouvernants tout à fait donc nous
allons nous espérons qu'ils vont pouvoir
rester chez nous que les études ne les
emmèneront pas ailleurs et puis qu'ils
ne seront pas appelés par les sirènes
d'autres clubs mais bon ça c'est aussi
notre notre fonction de former des
joueurs mais donc je pense que oui dans
quelques années nous aurons une équipe
seniors qui sera prometteuse comme de la
boue hui à quelques années j'ai c'est
une nouvelle génération de baseballeur
qui va abriter où on serre la réputation
de montigny c'est une réputation de
centre formateur un petit peu un vous
avez cette réputation de sortir les
jeunes pourquoi il n'y a pas cette
progression continue avec les seniors
pourquoi on n'arrive pas depuis deux
trois ans à remonter en élite avec les
seniors les jeunes ont du mal à a poussé
la porte un petit peu c'est ça où il y
avait pas encore la génération qu'il
fallait non je pense que les jeunes
n'ont pas du tout du mal à pousser la
peau puisque cette année certains
juniors ont été appelés à venir jouer
avec les seniors mais bon nous avons
comme politique aussi de laisser les
juniors en juniors pour qu'ils puissent
pour ne pas les abîmer pour ne pas les
fatiguer et puis le problème des seniors
c'est que bombay sont des jeunes
dans les seniors il ya des jeunes qui
font les études et qui sont appelés à
partir de nombreux sont partis aux états
unis faire leur faire leurs études
certains puisqu'on peut joue en atteint
sa plénitude de joueurs de baseball aux
alentours de 30 ans donc après il ya les
problèmes familiaux les problèmes
professionnels qui s'y disent qu'ils se
mêlent à ça et donc on sait très bien
que ce n'est pas avec le baseball qu'on
va gagner sa vie donc
en france et pas assez compliqué oui
donc c'est pour ça que parfois d'autres
sont appelés vers d'autres vers d'autres
régions pour pouvoir soit allé
travailler vont jouer et puis la
politique de montigny c'est on ne va pas
tout sacrifier pour avoir une équipe qui
joue en d1 avoir une équipe qui joue en
d1 ça demande beaucoup de finances que
nous n'avons pas puisque nous n'avons
pas beaucoup de partenaires nous
n'arrivons pas à trouver des partenaires
puisque le baseball est quand même un
sport assez confidentielle donc nous
préférons pour le moment nous préférons
garder les finances que nous avons à la
formation des jeunes nous ne voulons pas
sacrifier les jeunes à une équipe élite
très bien on les reverra donc dans
quelques mois parce que là c'est la
pause non les prévisions de baseball en
france marsoui donc là c'est place à la
préparation et à l'intersaison et donc
on vous retrouve début 2014 pour les
préparations en tout cas merci beaucoup
d'être passé sur le site sport est fier
à bientôt pour la nouvelle saison très
bientôt à l'intersaison place au
football féminin neuf joueuses du paris
saint germain sont arrivés à montigny on
reste toujours dans la même ville avec
une moyenne d'âge de 20 ans le groupe
s'est fortement rajeunie si l'ambiance
est là l'efficacité se fait encore
désirer avec cinq défaites en autant de
journées et 22 buts encaissés les vertes
sont la plus mauvaise défense du
championnat et surtout lanterne rouge
autant dire que jean dany gros c'est
l'entraîneur est sur un siège éjectable
comme nous le précise le président des
féminines philippe brunel et la
confiance du club parce que vous deux
victoires et on recolle tout de suite
dans le milieu de tableau effectivement
cette année la d2 le groupe de notre
groupe est beaucoup plus serré
effectivement il va pas falloir là il
faut obligatoirement chez les trois cas
de victoire avant le 8 décembre pour
pouvoir recoller donc il n'est pas
menacé pour on n'est pas menacée mais il
a comme l'impression du résultat ce qui
est normal pour un entraîneur d'une
équipe nationale alors comment lésigny
monteyne ont-elles réagi avec la
réception de dijon ce week-end plutôt
bien avec une première et belle victoire
récit de ce match
avec cinq défaites en autant de journées
le maintien il ôte un passé d'abord par
une première victoire face à dijon très
agressive les verts prennent cette fois
ci le match par le bon bout à la 12e
minute sur cette superbe ouverture de
tiffany pradier mélanie vie numérique à
part dans le dos de la défense tromper
la gardienne dijonnaise
l'ouverture du score donne confiance aux
saint quentinois ce qu'ils vont assister
quelques minutes plus tard au
chef-d'oeuvre de laëtitia mariani
2 0 après un quart d'heure de jeu
solidaire la smb gagnent la bataille du
milieu de terrain rendant vaine plus de
tentatives dijonnaise et c'est à croire
qu'il ne pouvait rien arriver aux jeux
de jordanie grosset même lorsque la
jeune alicia lazare est prise à défaut
elle dévient se centre sur la barre
transversale
à la demi-heure de jeu sur un nouveau
ballon arraché au milieu tiffany pradier
évite la sortie complètement ratée de la
gardienne 3 0 puis 4 0 par l'inévitable
mélanie ville mercat qui y va de son
doublé
seconde période les saint quentinois
salleron l'addition à trois reprises
pour l'emporter finalement 7 0 en un
match lésigny monteyne ont marqué trois
fois plus de but que lors des cinq
premières journées malgré cette première
victoire les vertes restent lanterne
rouge de leur groupe mais avec cette
combativité la leur avenir en d2 semble
s'éclaircir
j'en parlais dans les titres de ce sept
huit sports ce saint quentinois a
entrepris un challenge exceptionnel sidy
diallo ce week-end vous avez bouclé
votre 38e marathon en 2013 vous vous
êtes fixé un défi plutôt fou en fait de
courir 42 fois la distance cette année
bonsoir à vous
bonsoir ventoline d'abord il est que les
spectateurs puisque j'avais prévu d'être
au plateau ce soir avec guillemets par
le logement des contraintes
professionnelles point que en fait que
je m'entretiens vu tout au plus les
foules vous êtes tout excuser alors tout
d'abord première question qu'est ce qui
vous a pris de bain d'entreprendre ses
42 marathon cette année
écoutez on ce destin individuel en
demeure en disant je vais couvrir 40
cubains dont moi je suis nouveau dans le
monde du vin dans tous les angles j'ai
fait ma première course à peine trois
ans à chicago
ensuite en 2011 j'ai suis maintenant en
2012 j'ai pris tous on avait toutes les
tares du coup les bouches selon gala de
malte ont été annulés dans celui de new
york la dernière visite et j'ai dû
courir trop marathon en deux jours où
arrivèrent dans le biopic de 2012 les
courir le marathon et si tu raques
animation était la rochelle le 25
novembre
lui donne le 9 décembre et puis la mie
câline je fais descendre
ensuite après un contrôle en temps comme
ça un peu de fil et je me suis ivre j'ai
peut-être été retouché depuis sous
intrigues mais
je vais tenter en 2013 du coup les
canons des marathons c'est à dire dans
la tente où chaque édition de l'épreuve
et 42 marathon j'imagine qu'on doit
avoir une phase de préparation tout
particulièrement
malheureusement c'est une décision que
j'ai prise en fin d'année donc je
n'avais pas le temps de penser au
palacium particulière pour l'un d'eux
qu'ils ont si difficile alors ce que je
fais et puis si j'écoute revin en 28
jours peut-être trop avec cette chance
sur une année et donc je me suis lancée
sans savoir
si j'allais réussir au niveau physique à
vous parler ans et ça si vos capacités
physiques pouvait encaisser autant de
courses d'affilée voilà fallu je savais
que je n'avais qu'une idée puisque tu as
un terrain inconnu donc je me suis lancé
et lui le problème au départ
j'ai eu mal aux pieds le du pied et
surtout après avoir connu sur les pavés
et avait pas ron à kent et l'italie il y
avait beaucoup pleuré d'un fils de will
et bien suite
et alors je vous récupérez comment entre
entre deux courses puisque en fin de
compte vous courrez presque toutes les
semaines
mais que quand j'ai tout le marathon
j'ai pensé confier
le moratoire en cours mais dans une état
physique qui devait permettre de prendre
le départ donc je pense que j'irai
suivant qui fait que quand j'étais
j'avais des soucis des pieds avec
l'académie
qui toise le site internet vick a mené
le bal à 38 4 heures qui a un vrai que
c'est bien teachers qui le bat attendre
la grande muraille avec nous des excuses
discret il est beau tapis que sur le mur
doit voter les descendre plus des seuls
ils marchent démarche qui sont
différents différente de l'autre il fait
qu'il dispose de trois heures ce que
voulez
vous le disiez en votant à peu près 7
entre 3h22 un petit peu moins de cinq
heures sur la majorité des courses 42
courses pour le nombre de kilomètres
vous le disiez aussi est ce qu'il ya une
lassitude à courir toutes les semaines
comme cela un marathon ou au contraire
vous découvrir à chaque course
il dit j'ai appliqué quelques chaque
fois c'est quelque chose que vous et
d'ailleurs eu la chance à l'équipe de
marc étant que chaque année
coli ayant tous les autres villes du
coup il doit d'ailleurs sur les photos
qui ils sont diffusés à l'antenne un peu
tous les tous les marathons auxquels
vous avez pu découvrir ces derniers mois
est ce qu'avec autant de courses courues
dans une année vous avez des difficultés
par exemple pour trouver des courses
tout d'abord où des hébergements
la difficulté du doigt vous trouvez là
confie faiblement du clan parce qu'il
faudra trouver éventuellement de la
couche trouve plus à l'est
ensuite la langue feuillet comme wade
est aussi au moins d'eau moins de
truffes
oui j'imagine que ça doit être un budget
important de courir 42 marathon dans une
année dans wii ont tous les faits c'est
la question que tout le monde aimait
aussi compris d'être ouvert
j'espère que
ça vous a coûté combien pour l'instant
toutes ses courses cette année vous avez
déjà une petite estimations pas donc
je vais très bien merci beaucoup sidy
diallo d'avoir été quand même avec nous
par téléphone dans ce set 8 sport et
donc votre prochain marathon c'est du
côté de francfort en allemagne et bonne
continuation pour vos prochains défis je
m'inclus progression puis on a bientôt à
il s'appelle xavier bnr il a 31 ans et
partage sa vie entre les terrains de
volleyball et le technocentre de
guyancourt il est capitaine de l'équipe
de france de volley ball mais des sourds
depuis près de dix ans ce saint
quentinois a redoré en fin de compte un
le blason du volley ball français nous
l'avons rencontrée avec jonathan big man
xavier devient sort à l'âge d'un an à la
suite d'une méningite s'il parle c'est
grâce à des années de travail avec des
orthophonistes
il peut nous comprendre car il a appris
à lire sur les lèvres ma famille mes
parents
on est en groupe mon handicap temps pour
autant dire
rien faire qui le tour il est normal
comme un autre à 14 ans il claque ses
premiers ce match avec les valides à
amiens vous aviez découvre alors le
volet des sourds et de nouveaux repères
sur le terrain
non mais t'as retiendra
comme au début des années 2000 l'équipe
de france et lettre morte sept ans plus
tard il décide de la remettre sur pied
en 2011 la sélection fini 6e des
championnats d'europe puis à nouveau
sixième aux mondiaux l'année suivante
malgré ces bons résultats les volleyeurs
tricolores ne sont pas médiatisés mais
cela ne dérange pas le guyancourt toi
lnf l'impôt et là c'est encore moi qui
vais
au concert d'hommage
aux
salariés de renault depuis 2005 il
travaille actuellement sur les moteurs
électriques de la marque au technocentre
xavier communique grâce à un outil de
discussions par votre came avec l'aide
d'un interprète qui retranscrit la
discussion langue des signes quand il
n'est pas au bureau ils jouent en
championnat de france des sourds avec le
stade parisien club qu'il a lui même
créée et xavier continue d'affronter les
valides au niveau départemental son
dernier objectif sur le terrain monter
sur les podiums des championnats
d'europe à paris en 2015
allez on passe au sprint aux résultats
du week-end
alors tout d'abord on va passer au
football première étape de ces résultats
si après six journées de division
d'honneur versailles est enfin débloqué
le compteur victoire vous le voyez ça
s'affiche les joueurs de david giguet se
sont imposés à domicile face à sa mort
lusitanos 2-1 et empoche là leur premier
succès de la saison qui leur permet de
remonter à la septième place au
classement général de dh en promotion
d'honneur toujours en foot le parcours
est toujours aussi sinueux pour hui en
cours pour le compte de la 4e journée le
sg s'est incliné à unis 3-1 et reste
englué dans le bas du classement de sa
poule à la 11e place dans la poule b
sera pas conservé son invincibilité des
trappistes se sont imposés à domicile
sur le plus petit des scores 1 0 face à
noisy le grand et au classement
justement les trappistes restent
toujours deuxièmes on voit le classement
qui s'affiche avec 14 points à deux
longueurs du leader nanterre autre
équipe invaincue cette saison chez les
femmes on parlait de montigny tout à
l'heure en promotion d'honneur 3e
journée l'encours a concédé le match nul
à domicile face à nicolette chaillot 3
partout les amazones reste 9e et
avant-dernière de leur poule en rugby
cinquième journée de fédérale 3 plaisir
s'est facilement défait de pontault
combault au stade robert barran dimanche
victoire du prc 21,9 et les joueurs de
philibert sont désormais deuxièmes de
leur poule à cinq points du leader
orléans en d'honneur cette fois ci la 4e
journée a moins souri aux cayes rugby
les saint quentinois n'ont rien pu faire
face à cergy-pontoise défaite 34 à 10
encaissant six essais ils sont 8e et
dernier de leur poule mais avec deux
matches de retard place au basket
toujours dans le sport de ballon
week-end difficile pour les féminines de
l'entente le chesnay versailles en
nationale une des coéquipières de
virginie aurensan se sont inclinés à
domicile face à feytiat 53 à 64 et
retombe à la huitième place de leur
poule à leurs homologues masculins se
sont en revanche imposé à césaire
levillain 80 à 66 de son côté trappe à
nouveau régner sur un derby yvelinois
face à poissy cette fois-ci courte
victoire 52 à 48 qui place les cheminots
de trappes à la quatrième place de cette
poule j de n3 et en tennis de table
autres sports qui marche bien sur le
saint quentin en yvelines pour le compte
de la troisième journée de national de
l'entente voisin saint-arnoult recevait
seclin au complexe sportif des pyramides
et les joueuses de geoffrey nisand ligue
aussi très bien les matchs de simple
avec mon mais la porte à
impériale mais les saint quentinois se
laisse surprendre en double par les
jeunes nordistes qui recolle à six
matchs à 4 grâce au simple décisif
l'entente s'impose finalement 8 5 et
empoche sa troisième victoire
consécutive et reste évidemment leader à
égalité de points avec coutances saint
lô dans la poularde toujours du tennis
de table il ya il encourt 1 que l'on
suit également et les ans le courtois se
déplacer à la trinité dans les
alpes-maritimes mais ce
non pas à rivaliser en fin de compte 1
défaite 8-2 les élans courtoise son 7e
de leur poule encore deux infos avant de
nous quitter tout d'abord du football
toujours pour le paris saint germain
vous le savez intensité pour accueillir
le centre d'entraînement du psg le
projet de poissy a été officiellement
écarté ce vendredi à la suite d'une
réunion du conseil régional
d'ile-de-france et d'un amendement porté
par les verts visant à protéger 20
hectares de terres agricoles contre
l'urbanisation
selon nos confrères du parisien vous le
voyez cela sa fiche le psg aurait
prioriser le camp des loges et
saint-germain-en-laye avec une zone au
nord de la forêt de saint germain en
laye pour implanter le futur centre
d'entraînement et si la mention de la
commune des yvelines a perdu de son
importance sur le logo du club ce
dossier tient la corde et devraient
aboutir ainsi rien ne vient perturber
les discussions en cours d'ailleurs une
réunion technique a eu lieu entre les
représentants de la ville yvelinoise du
club et de la ville de paris et le psg
dépenserait alors 50 millions d'euros
pour se porter acquéreur de ce terrain
de 60 hectares au complet à mon probable
décision qu'a tenu un vous l'avez vu
dans les images à démentir le club
l'illinois sur son site internet enfin
dernière info c'est du vélo au club au
vélo-club d'elancourt de saint quentin
en yvelines on compte on connaît
évidemment la revancharde que vous voyez
sur ces images les challenge ufolep que
l'on suit tous les ans un sur tv film
est pas encore le handbike le club saint
quentinois vient de créer sa section
handisport une section présidée par eric
castaldi et ces jeunes spécialistes
d'handisport pourront bientôt profiter
un des installations du vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines dès l'hiver
prochain je vous le rappelle
l'inauguration officielle est prévue le
28 janvier 2014 enfin l'agenda du
week-end évidemment pour terminer ce set
8 sport tout d'abord du tir à l'arc
montigny accueille une étape
qualificative pour les championnats de
france ce week-end tir prévu tout le
week end ailleurs au gymnase pierre de
coubertin vous voyez ça s'affiche et la
deuxième date c'est la frappadingue nous
avions nous vous avions fait découvrir
le mode des il ya quelques semaines si
vous n'avez pas été associés eh bien
vous pourrez vous risquez à la
frappadingue à mon talent et le bois à
l'aise de mantes-la-jolie départ
dimanche prochain à 9h30 c'est la fin de
ce set 8 faut remercier encore une fois
de l'avoir suivi et n'hésite pas à nous
donner tous les résultats de vos clubs
et commentez l'émission sur les réseaux
sociaux et twitter avec le hashtag le
7-8 sport tout attaché à lundi prochain
bonne soirée